we're proud to report that pixel
received a rating of 89
that's the highest reading ever for a
smartphone HTC u11 camera the highest
and the only one with the highest score
the exo mark has issued pixel to an
unprecedented score of 98 that's the
highest score of any smartphone camera
stop guys I'm Kim PhD here recently the
Google pixel 2 came out with the highest
ever rating of a smartphone camera on
DxO mark again Google tweeted it
Google's CEO tweeted it a whole bunch of
people put it in their headlines
it's shone like a badge of honor every
time it happens but why I mean we've
talked about smartphone cameras in the
past but suddenly in the past 2 or 3
years
DxO mark ratings have become the holy
grail of measuring smartphone camera
quality so this is DxO mark explained so
DxO labs measures and rates a bunch of
different cameras sensors and lenses
some dslr's some cine cameras Canon
glass Nikon glass all that stuff and
they have an entire separate section
dedicated to smartphone cameras if you
click on this mobile section of the site
you'll see this hierarchy of smartphone
cameras each of them with a big number
rating this is somewhat accurate but
also a bit misleading using one single
number to describe and to encompass all
the complexities that go into a
smartphone camera is a bit too broad
it's just a little bit crazy in my
opinion so DxO breaks it down into photo
and video and then bricks each of those
down into a bunch of subcategories so if
you scroll down far enough in a DxO
smartphone camera view underneath the
rating you'll see that breakdown of the
subset scores for photos and for videos
pixel to for example got a 99 for photos
and a 96 for video but you notice these
numbers clearly aren't an average of the
sub scores so they have this weighting
system essentially their own algorithm
for combining all of the sub scores into
this overall score so it's that score
that gets published and plastered all
over the internet all over your Twitter
feeds but most of these are
chuckles in fact probably all of them
ignored the sub scores and how well
these cameras did in each category you'd
have to actually go to DxO marks site
and actually scroll all the way down and
read through the review for that and if
you did you would find that DxO does
some pretty legit really solid testing
they try to be scientific and objective
wherever they possibly can they have a
bunch of these indoor sets these
controlled environments for testing
things like noise performance sharpness
color reproduction and detail in the
exact same situation for every phone so
it's repeatable every time for testing
boko with portrait mode they have a
foreground subject and a background
that's a certain distance away they
measure autofocus speed and shutter
speed lag with moving subjects the whole
deal and then they also have a bunch of
slightly less exact but still pretty
telling
outdoor tests for things like high
dynamic range and seeing color casts etc
according to their site they have quote
more than 50 challenging and realistic
indoor and outdoor scenes then they turn
these photo samples into ratings for
each category using a panel of experts
they say and essentially what they do is
they take the new image from the
smartphone camera and match it with the
closest one on a scale with what's
called an image quality ruler they have
an existing scale with a bunch of
different levels of noise for example
and they match the new sample with where
it falls on that scale so that's how
they turn a qualitative measurement into
a quantitative value but these websites
reporting on the new phones when they
come out you know they don't really want
all that that's a little too much for a
headline so DxO is smart and to make it
more easy to headline they summarized
everything into one big overall score
which like I mentioned is not the
average of the sub score so we can
assume they're weighted roughly in that
order with exposure and contrast being
the most important auto focus and color
being almost as important and this
decision of the order that they weight
things is subjective the order that they
decide to rank these and the amount of
weight that they put into each one is
entirely up to them and that's why you
shouldn't put all your purchase decision
into just the overall score
you should look past the overall rating
compiling everything into one overall
score can be misleading because
different characteristics matter to
different people some people take a lot
of low-light photos or take a lot of
photos of people a lot of selfies or a
lot of landscape shots here's a perfect
example the Galaxy Note 8 got an overall
score of 94 the pixel 2 got an overall
score of 98 you take a lot of portrait
photos which one are you gonna pick
you're gonna pick the Galaxy Note 8
you're gonna throw out the overall score
and pick the one that actually has a
dedicated second camera for portrait
photos if you look at the photo sub
scores it got a way higher score for
zoom and bokeh but these are pretty new
things and so they're not really
weighted as heavily so they don't really
have nearly as much of an effect on that
overall score and as a result the phone
that you would pick because it's better
for what you like got a lower overall
score on the DxO mark scale you see what
I'm getting at honestly most of these
smartphone cameras are great when you
talk about things like contrast and
color and dynamic range to varying
degrees obviously but the top ones are
all pretty good the bigger difference
comes with the different modes with
things like portrait mode and long
exposure and panorama stitching and all
that those are what make a bigger
difference to the user experience
especially when you see a phone like
pixel to doing portrait mode mostly
within the software versus with a second
camera now here's another reason you may
want to look past the overall score
DxO Labs is a consulting company as well
as a testing company for a fee they will
work with smartphone manufacturers
before their phone comes out to create a
better camera so they'll provide their
their testing software their hardware
and their testing methodology so that
you can calibrate your sensor and your
image processing pipeline to produce
better photos but also kinda to just do
better on their tests it's pretty easy
to look at this and think they were just
working with you to get a higher score
now I'm not saying that smartphone
manufacturers are specifically tuning
their cameras to do better on deck so
mark instead of actually doing what's
better for the consumer but it's a
blurry line there it's kind of similar
to what we see with benchmark I mean
most of the things that do better on DxO
mark are also better for the camera but
again it's combining it it's tuning it
to their exact specs and with those
better with their methodology basically
if you don't work with
them on tuning your camera sweet you'll
get a lower score and if you don't have
that DxO mark money you're kind of left
out on the cold they might not even test
your phone so you can take all that with
a grain of salt obviously I don't think
DxO mark is changing their test results
based on who paid obviously the
reputation is based off of objectivity
and scientific accuracy in a way so they
wouldn't want to risk that but the
simple fact that they partner up with
certain manufacturers and work on
certain devices while they don't with
others is kind of an awkward
relationship
imagine if Geekbench imagine if the
benchmarking suite Geekbench partnered
with certain manufacturers on improving
overall device performance and then also
made a big deal about which one scored
better in Geekbench you see how weird
that might be anyway moving on to
another quick point with the pixel to
getting a 98 you're probably wondering
what's the best score they've ever given
to any camera that would be a 108 and
that was the sensor score for the red
helium 8 k with the super 35 sensor
though when you've been watching footage
from for this whole video now if you're
thinking wait a minute
if combining all the sub score values
makes a value higher than the average
and they gave a value of a hundred and
eight for a sensor in a different test
how what how you get a score over a
hundred sitting on top of it all with
its current sensor the helium 8 KS 35
with a DX ohm mark score of 108 yes
that's supposed to be out of a hundred
nope that's no no it's not the XO mark
scores are not out of a hundred that the
pixel two did not get a 98 out of 100
it's not a ninety-eight percent I see
way too many tech news outlets reporting
DxO ratings as if they're like close to
a perfect score because they think
they're out of a hundred they're not the
fact that they're close to 100 is great
but that's purely a coincidence and
cameras are gonna keep getting better on
this linear scale and they're going to
reach and pass a hundred there's gonna
be a first smartphone to hit a hundred
they're gonna make a huge deal about
that you're gonna see it in every
headline and then there's gonna be the
first smartphone to pass 100 they're
gonna make a big deal about that too and
that's gonna make a lot of headlines
again but there is no maximum or perfect
score the fact that there are near 100
right now like I said is a pure
coincidence and it's a result of their
weighting system
that it pushes those numbers up to near
100 and that's why in the past year or
two they kind of get reported more often
because they look like a near perfect
score but again it's just a coincidence
they will keep going above 100 that's
just the way it is for now so the whole
thing about every new smartphone camera
being the new highest ever rating on DXL
mark while it's kind of annoying right
now that's supposed to happen it's just
getting reported more it's kind of like
when Apple says up their keynotes
this is the fastest iPhone we've ever
made well I hope it's the fastest iPhone
you've ever made you shouldn't be making
slower phones from last year but you
don't see anyone like Geekbench rating
these chips on a scale and then giving a
new crown to the highest ever rating
every time it just doesn't work that way
my problem isn't with DxO mark it's
really more with the press they just
kind of have a habit of parroting the
new highest overall score and not really
looking too far into it or putting any
effort into reporting that too
it's nice when they do but for the most
part they're just trying to get their
clicks so if you're on the other side of
this and you're actually reading these
reviews and these ratings you just got
to look a little bit more into it
actually read the review if you're
thinking about making a purchase so keep
doing your thing DxO mark now if you
want to bundle everything into one
overall score that's representative of
the phone that's cool just try to
surface a little bit more information
more easily and if you're in tech press
and you write a new article every time
there's a new highest DxO mark score but
you don't write a new article every time
there's a new highest Geekbench score
think about what you're doing stop it
get some help so in summary DxO mark
does real testing yes but an overall
number to describe everything that goes
into a camera is a little too broad yes
and then DxO also does consulting to
improve cameras based on their own
algorithms and testing so maybe take
those numbers with a grain of salt and
the score is just happened to be around
100 right now but that's purely a
coincidence they are not out of 100 so
what we've learned here is ratings are a
nice clean even number to point to one
being better than the other but if you
actually want to make a purchase
decision you got to look a little bit
deeper than the DxO mark rating plus
they're all pretty incredible anyway you
should watch the blind test I'll link it
below either way that's been it thank
you for watching talk to you guys the
next one
peace
[Music]